what would you tell that 17 year old
girl about what lies ahead of her
well the one thing i would definitely
say is don't sweat it like i used to
stress
out so much when i was 17 about the
littlest things
um everything felt like it was you know
the world would come crashing down and
um i think
now 20 years since then i can definitely
turn around and say that
you know take a breath smell the roses
drink some coffee
love life it's great oh my gosh
pre i hope you're staying safe in london
because i know you're filming a
text uh text for you so are you staying
safe everything's going on okay on that
one
we've just wrapped text for you and i'm
prepping for citadel now which i get
into
um but you know it's a scary time and to
be on a set
um i know it's it's allowed by
government laws for us to be able to
shoot but
just as an actor i'm the only one who's
like really taking off my mask you know
and it's like
scary to to think about that um
but you know um the best part is all
productions are being so
so careful with testing and we're
distancing that i feel kind of safe as
well
good good you are not only a star but
honey you are also bringing us content
that brings you know south asian stories
to the forefront
was that always the plan all along for
you when it came to producing to bring
stories of people of color to the
forefront to show them to empower them
to let their stories be heard and seen
i mean for sure when i started my
production company in india
um the the stories that i started
telling were not mainstream stories i
started with regional stories because
i i learned very young very early in my
career
that i have a platform which can you
know sort of propel
um opportunity or where it doesn't exist
and when i started working in the u.s
and
um you know started working on producing
like the reason i actually
fought for white tiger i called i got my
agents to call
the producers i met rameen four times i
said
i'll audition for you i'll do whatever
but you're not making this movie without
me
because i read the book and it was so
compelling to me and i know this is one
of those stories
that originate from india but is
completely universal the class disparity
that we see and we've recently seen
um even in the us um it's it's
massive and you know it's super topical
and to me it's very very important to
tell stories
south asian stories are truly important
to me female stories and people of color
it's extremely important
i'm pinkie nice to meet you well wrong
have you ever seen a computer we had
many of them in the village with the
goats
the goats are pretty advanced to his
computer now you're being a jerk
this movie is phenomenal i can't wait to
go back and and read the book but
it is incredible and adarsh you know i
hear that
our star i know dude you knock it out of
the park and i tell you i hear that they
had an extensive search
to find the perfect person to be cast in
the role
of balram and here you are you get the
part
and what does it feel like to you yeah i
just feel incredibly lucky that
you know i got to work with a team like
this and got to work with uh
with rameen as a director because it's
the amount of artistic freedom that all
of us got as actors
was incredible um you know right from uh
the first audition that i had with
somebody he just allowed
um he just allowed me to fly with it you
know he gave me so much space to work
with and
included me at every junction of the
film you know even if it was
for the clothes i wear for the kind of
things that would be in my office you
would ask me what kind of things do you
think
would be in your office well once you
were you know the business man or what
you know do you like this shirt or do
you like this one better so when you get
so personally involved with like a film
character then it's it's just very
difficult for you to not give
uh everything that you have to it and
you know like i think the three to four
months that i spent with the film
including the shooting for it was
probably the biggest uh
it was probably the biggest learning
curve of my life just to be on it and
even offset when i was prepping for it
it was incredible i just feel very lucky
well honey you put everything into it
and it is evident because your work is
is fantastic in the film what was it
like having miss
priyanka chopra jonas as your boss
come on i was i was so intimidated the
first time i
had to go meet her and we met her we
went at her house for a for the reading
and i was in my pants when i was on on
my own
how is how is this going to be you know
i just i just kept
kept telling myself that i've just got
to be normal it's all right she's also a
human being
and you know it's going to be fine and i
walked in
and uh raj and rameen were already there
and you know
she just came and hugged me and then we
sat and spoke and i was so comfortable
like in five minutes of being in a house
i completely forgot that i was
sitting next to like a global star and
uh you know
that's such a cute puppy that you have
on the couch and so i got so distracted
spike sorry mike is such a scene stiller
but um
i gotta say pre is she has an effect on
people she's just she'll just make you
feel
special even if you haven't done
anything special are you just nice about
yourself around her that's
that's what i realized the power of free
right
i love that instagram post that you just
put out there it said
lean mean in all of 17. pre what would
you tell that 17 year old girl about
what lies ahead of her
well the one thing i would definitely
say is don't sweat it like i used to
stress out so much when i was 17 about
the littlest things
um everything felt like it was you know
the world would come crashing down and
um i think now
20 years since then i can definitely
turn around and say that
you know take a breath smell the roses
drink some coffee
love life it's great exactly and
hopefully part of life you know i read
recently you said you wanted to have a
cricket sized
family what does nick think about that
does he want maybe a chess team instead
or maybe a basketball team i mean
cricket that's what like 11 players come
on now free
yeah that was a statement i made many
years ago what i was trying to say
was don't hold on to statements that i
made like
10 years ago um i don't know you know
i'll take whatever i can get when it
comes to
nick and i well hopefully it'll be soon
because we need some more
joe grow babies out there honey and that
they're going to be talented and
beautiful i can tell you well stop with
the pressure
look at this big ass movie that's coming
out right now no pressure no pressure
just saying pre just
us girls talking but i gotta ask you
finally the current state of the
industry look
we're seeing our second spike in covid
right now we're also seeing films
being rolled out in streaming platforms
and on demand more frequently
this too this movie is another case in
that point
what do you make of where the industry
is going to go from here
i definitely think between covid and
between
you know the internet and the streaming
services that have come in the industry
has changed
it's never going to go back to that time
when you know we only had theatrical
releases
um but for sure i feel like it's the
evolution of entertainment and the
evolution of the business of
entertainment kovit has shown us that
you know this is the beginning and this
we as a world are super vulnerable but
it's also shown us that we're also
resilient
look at the way we've sort of adapted to
being able to do interviews like this
you and i would be sitting in front of
each other and having this conversation
but
you know we're all three of us are in
three different parts of the world and
we're doing this
so the show keeps going on and i feel
like you know
this is going to be an evolution it's
going to be something to watch out for
but i don't think theatrical is really
going anywhere
because when you want to watch that
amazing movie you want to get your
popcorn you want to sit with people
i think once the world opens up and we
can actually meet people again
people are going to want to go to the
movies
you